Nabilla Zahia et Ribéry sont les
personnalités les moins aimées des
Français on n'a pas le droit de
stigmatiser toute une famille comme ça
d'accueille maintenant
[Applaudissements]
joyeux Noël
enfin c'est chouette comme fait quoi on
se rassemble en famille on boit des
coups et on regarde Maman j'ai raté
l'avion 5 sur TF1
petit conseil aux enfants qui sont en
train de courir autour du sapin comme
c'est l'année du Qatar remplacer les
souliers par des babouches ça va plus
bon sinon qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
enfin le monde avance Mandela est enfin
enterré ça maladie va enfin pouvoir
souffler un peu
ouais parce que six mois d'aller venue à
la fin à la grippe aussi elle est malade
quoi un peu plus quoi politique
nationale la Centrafrique ça avance aux
dernières nouvelles Hollande aurait
retrouvé l'avion pour rentrer donc c'est
c'est chic en ce moment il voyage
beaucoup pauvre petit chat
à courroux sur le site de lancement des
fusées Ariane il s'est senti comme un
poisson dans l'eau c'est normal c'est
une fusée c'est quoi c'est c'est un
dispositif qui explose le décollage une
fois sur deux pour terminer en orbite
dans le vide intersidéral à peu de
choses près le destin d'une loi du
gouvernement héros
[Applaudissements]
le 29 et 30 décembre il a prévu de se
rendre en Arabie Saoudite il aime le
challenge ça c'est est-ce qu'il va
arriver à faire pleuvoir là-bas
à propos de nuages en ce moment il y en
a eu des très sombres cette polémique
sur ce fameux rapport sur l'intégration
ça fait beaucoup de beaucoup de vagues
c'est un merveilleux rapport enfin
réécrire l'histoire c'est chouette
Charles Martel se dangereux rétrograde
nazi qui s'est battu à l'arbe blanche
contre les nobles défenseurs de la
cantine halal dans les régions au-dessus
de la Loire ça va être alors il y a une
chose le rapport est très bien écrit
j'ai compilé la langue du rapport qui
est d'une beauté je cite faire France
dans un ou inclusif et solidaire qui
permettrait de faire de l'encrement à
travers une nouvelle forme
d'universalité au bénéfice de tous dans
tu écris un truc pareil au bac philo non
seulement terre Calais mais en plus on
annule ton brevet des collèges tu vois
quand Hollande a su pour le rapport il a
dit ouais il faut pas effrayer les
Français avant les élections c'est vrai
il devrait en profiter parce que eux ils
risquent de l'effrayer pendant
mais ça ça veut dire un truc ça veut
dire qu'en fait c'est même pas une
tactique pour faire monter le Front
national non le mec il est sincère
je pensais qu'on l'avait un mec qui
jouait au con pour enfumer tout le monde
mais en fait non non c'est c'est Mr Bean
c'est lui c'est bien lui
alors certains disent certains disent
qu'ils devraient remanier pourquoi faire
il y a les meilleurs
monarchie qui n'a aucun rapport alors il
est né le divin enfant fruit de garde et
de Charlotte on n'a pas encore sa photo
mais on peut d'ores et déjà dire qu'il a
l'argent de son père et l'argent de sa
mère
[Applaudissements]
international les athées humanistes et
libres penseurs risquent la peine de
mort dans 13 pays alors j'ai regardé la
liste des pays c'est bizarre Mauritanie
Soudan Somalie Iran
Arabie Saoudite
Qatar Pakistan Afghanistan et je me dis
mais
c'est quoi le truc en commun
je suis sûr je suis je suis sûr qu'il y
a un truc mais je vois pas je vais
peut-être plus tard dans le je sais pas
je trouve pas tu vas le trouver je vais
trouver peut-être inch'Allah
cinéma il est mort le plus grand acteur
qui est porté la Corrèze Peter
humanisme des employés ont perdu leur
emploi via SMS alors comme quoi on fait
des progrès c'est vachement plus humain
ça rappelle les ruptures amoureuses
divertissement alors on la démantelé un
réseau de pub chinoise dans les caves
des tours du 13e arrondissement des nems
à la chez les Chinois tout semble
rouler dans un endroit sombre et humide
[Applaudissements]
amour
Nabilla Zahia et Ribéry sont les
personnalités les moins aimées des
Français on n'a pas le droit de
stigmatiser toute une famille comme ça
c'est moche
statistique il paraît que 27% des
délinquants sont étrangers ouf
Montebourg peut être content ça veut
dire que globalement la délinquance
reste un truc made in France
crime un braquage a été commis avec les
masques de François Hollande oui c'est
vrai que des en déguisé en c'est sûr que
si on peut neutraliser les victimes avec
un regard c'est
en cas de non efficacité les braqueurs
imitent la voix Duflot aussi c'est
là généralement ça marche
sexualité vintage un homme blessé par un
obus de 39-45 alors on ne le dit jamais
assez en matière de sextoy toujours
utilisé du matière neuf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors il y a une bonne nouvelle mais que
j'ai que j'ose pas faire parce que je
pense que c'est vraiment ça pourrait
tellement mieux convenir à Stéphane donc
je vais si tu veux bien sûr je veux pas
je t'en prie
bonne nouvelle Nadine Morano tête de
liste aux Européennes dans le Grand Est
je ne sais pas vous mais moi Stéphane
Guillon j'ai hâte de voter pour elle
enfin sauf si le FN propose une
alternative plus à droite
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et mettez un pouce bleu